yo what's going on it's your boy little
TJ and these are 10 Things I can't live
without
[Music]
my jewels of course Jerry don't make a
guy I'm saying but I definitely do feel
like I got a different like energy on
you when I got my chains on I feel like
it just it felt good I like the glow it
get me and I'm saying I like how I light
up the room
no it felt good so I definitely always
got my juice with me I was starting up
like
um trench kid and making it an LLC and
putting it together I made my Design
This is actually the logo got a richer
Millie watch I don't have it on right
now but I got this watch too he got it
too the eyes glow in the dark
oh
foreign
[Music]
spray go a long way for me Sprite Sprite
my favorite soda like sometimes I'll be
having mood swings I'll be cheating on
my spray sometimes getting something
else but it should be on me since the
cast on my my favorite baby
I'm the type of person I go into the
Exotic pop store and just go crazy just
grab wild that you feel me nobody
never seen before but my grandma just be
posting that form snacks and too
like I'd be adventurous but I like
feeling it all feeling it'll probably
come next any particularly with a burger
fries
Pizza
sturdy hey this is evaluable mostly
anything
all right one of the main things I need
to live my day-to-day life is my phone I
bust all my moves off the phone it just
helped me stay organized know what I
gotta do probably the most important
thing I have to water them there I need
my day-to-day apps is really Instagram
for for Instagram and I might play like
a little phone game I got this game
called killer bean it's like a little
shooting game fight I probably am
addicted to my phone sometimes I don't
even watch movies and TVs because I
can't get into it because I always get
back in shot through my phone on some
facts I've been listening to oil table
I've been listening like damn near
drill sometimes I'll be having my r
b moods I even hop in like pop country
sometimes I'm with scissors
right now I like snooze I know Ed
Sheeran you got that heat you for me for
people like me peripheral like new
generation like polo one of my favorite
artists I'll be listening like a lot of
Polo
[Music]
my next essential is a good pair of feet
you know just go what I was saying when
you got like memes and can't be out here
look at any type of way my sure Choice
today is these ones I'm saying red and
black it's the Chicago Ones yeah good
pit Feats that's definitely you know
what I'm saying that's definitely an
essential I wouldn't consider myself a
sneak ahead but like
because I feel like the background and
like the education behind what comes
with this I don't got it you know
what I'm saying but I definitely love me
a good pair of feets Air Force Ones for
sure is mandatory that's like that's
what I should have had right now with me
I'm saying I could have had those with
me right now 365 in a year like no
exaggeration I'm buying 85 pair UPS
[Music]
that's one of the most important
Essentials some condoms I
ain't really a thing for like that for
me I'm more of a subtle guy I'm saying
when it's that time I'm gonna use these
right here Safety First
my next essential is a lighter
preferably big because I feel like it's
the most reliable they go the best
Against the Wind and they kind of look
the drippiest second kind of you got the
other ones and just like it's like this
is the designer of the lighter he might
use this for a couple of things you know
I'm saying one of my favorite things to
use this for
that's how many damn saying I like
backwards I had like a pair like a
four-year run to just backwards for some
reason I just left Jamaica that's part
of the reason and I was smoking like a
lot of papers and I've been back for
like less than 24 and I adjust back to
my woods yet but yeah I'm a backwards
type of girl
foreign
[Music]
yeah I lose a lot of sunglasses for sure
I'll be buying sunglasses to go on my
outfit occasionally I definitely like to
match my sunglasses with the brand I'm
wearing most of the time LV yeah lV for
sure but I got the most out of you
glasses out of any brand I think the
sunglasses wave really just came about
but it's heavy right now but I've been
wearing glasses for like about like
seven eight months like more
and yeah I'm kicking up with them
my next essential is a hat bucket hats
is my swag I ain't gonna lie some cool
about bucking hats I feel like they just
not over saturated it's probably why I
like them like that but in this case we
got two flavors not even particularly
these but just hatch you know in general
because you know what they're out for
got a little bad hair day I'm saying
throw this one you're sturdy you're
saying it's just like the glasses I'm
good accessory I had a Louis V bucket at
the other day Paint I had the um strings
with the you got to put the picture that
go thing family got the strings and I
had like two little Louis V songs paint
yeah you know what's crazy I got a song
I say in New York but I hate wearing
bull cap normally I'm saying my bucket
has my Essential bad head there it's a
little sauce right now through the
little sir why would you describe your
style though they're gonna have to
Humble me I think I got the best drip in
the world I ain't even trying to say
right now I'm sitting a little bit but
for me I ain't gonna lie go to Brand
right now Louis V Louis
our next essential is some Jamaican food
right now we ain't got no Jamaican food
I got this menu right here
oxtail rest in peace
party I like all this it's making
swallow smashing fire I don't like this
when they be having a fake
they're trying to copy the culture they
don't know what they're doing I like the
logistics
[Music]
holds everything down I'm saying I need
my walls have my card to pay the bills
my ID sometimes I leave my wallet I let
my security on my wallet
sometimes if it's like because it might
be too much and it might up my
outfit just look too funny on me my
password off real quick
they carry cash sometimes
sometimes I build cash too fast when I
got it I keep pulling that out or
tell somebody pay me cash because cash
be flying for me but I always got that
car I won't even be going too too crazy
on the flavors with the wallets I could
like go a little crazy up but I didn't
be thinking about that too much but
I enjoyed James ain't got that wallet
and other purposes but you know
that's a wrap it's your boy little TJ
man shout out to GQ thanks for having me
foreign